Knowing what you know about war and the teams, if you could go back in time,
what would you have done differently? Man, I wish I could go back in
time day. Berg and I are doing an event, uh,
earlier this week and he was, he, he said, uh, you know,
I'm glad I'm not Ramadi. I know lave probably wishes he was everybody 100%.
I would go there right now. Yeah, let's go. Um,
and it's what I would do differently is the recognition that uh,
we were super aggressive. We took a lot of risk. Um,
what I would do differently is I would actually be even more aggressive.
I would be a hundred times more aggressive. I would be putting up, you know,
a concept operations brief for your,
for your approval to send up the chain to swim across the river and hit targets
and, and you know,
put in some cyber Overwatch's it and just completely ruined the bad guys program
going on in south central. My,
when they had complete freedom movement before they had any expectation that we
could be there before I could get to us. And I think, uh,
they would never see a common, which means that a,
we would have more impact and it would actually be safer for us, uh,
because they wouldn't mix back in it. So they would probably hammer hammers.
But we, we recognize that we could get away with a lot more, um, you know,
than we could. Uh, and looking back on it, I just, when you,
when you come into an area and they're like, hey,
don't go in and you're all going to get killed, he, you want to be cautious.
You wanna you don't want to just jump into things.
You want to mitigate risk and control. Certainly. Uh,
but we recognize we could get away with a lot more than we thought we could.
And more often than not, bring, bring guys home. And of course,
that's the one thing I would change. Obviously, if I could change, if, uh,
I would trade places with Mark Lee and Ryan, Joe and my platoon in a second,
uh, I'd trade places with Mike Montour and [inaudible] and in a second,
and I wish I could do that. Uh, and I can't, but, uh, that is the,
that is what I would change. Um, but, uh, I certainly would, uh,
if we could go back to her again,
we would be even more aggressive and we'd have even more impact.
There's a term that they used to say in the teams,
I don't know if you've ever heard it.
You probably did when we'd be doing special reconnaissance training and guys
would say, trust your camouflage. Did you ever hear that expression?
You may not have. I don't. I don't believe so.
So what it was was when you got good at putting your camouflage together,
you could really get aggressive in getting up and observing a target.
Because if you trust your camera,
if you've done a good job with your Cammie paint, your Ghillie suit and, and,
and putting yourself together, well the enemy's not gonna be able to see you.
But it's really weird to be, you know,
40 meters from a target that you're looking at.
Then there's a guy walking around and you feel completely naked.
Like they can see what they can't see you at all. They can't see you at all.
And so it takes them, it takes them time to learn, to trust your camouflage.
And I think, you know,
obviously hindsight is 2020 and when you look back at your Marty like you look
back and you think to yourself, well, we could have done this.
We could have done that. We could've gotten closer to that target.
We could have done more things
because our,
hindsight's 2020 and also we learned over time to trust our camouflage.
And the longer we were there, the the, the more aggressive, you know,
operations took place. But yeah, that's,
hindsight's 2020 isn't it? That it is.